at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking this episode is brought to you
by wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront is a massively
disruptive in a good way set it and
forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront
so the question is why why is it so
popular why is it unique because you can
get services previously reserved for the
ultra wealthy but only pay pennies on
the dollar for them and this is because
they use smarter software instead of
retail locations bloated sales teams etc
and I'll come back to that in a second I
suggest you check out wealthfront com
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they put you
in and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it and here's why the value
of wealthfront is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally aren't great investing is a
marathon not a sprint and little things
that you may or may not be familiar with
like automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront as i mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first fifteen thousand which is managed
for free if you use my link wealthfront
com forward slash Tim that is less than
five dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor around
the shows because I use the
and recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of this episode is
brought to you by 99designs 99designs
is a great partner for creating and
growing your business it's a one-stop
shop for all of your graphic design
needs whether that's a logo website
business card or anything else I use 99
designs to get book cover prototypes for
the 4-hour body which went on to become
a number one New York Times best seller
and I also use them for banner ads
illustrations and other things with
99designs designers around the world to
compete to create the best design for
you you give feedback and then pick your
favorite you end up happy or you get
your money back it's very simple you can
check out a few of my own designs and
those of yours meaning Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99designs calm /if Tim and
right now my listeners you guys will get
a free $99 upgrade on your first design
that's 99designs dot-com a forward slash
Tim check it out
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show I'm sitting outside on
a beautiful summer day listening to the
birds and my job is usually to
deconstruct world-class performers to
tease out the routines habits and so on
that you can use from people at the top
of whatever field they happen to be a
part of military entertainment politics
chess athletics you name it
in this particular episode I'm going to
share an overarching strategy that has
been used by many of the greats
that includes Ben Franklin it includes
legendary NFL coach Bill Belichick and
many many more it is also how I built my
network how my first book hit the
tipping point how I became successful
angel investing and the list goes on of
course if you're interested in the
networking part of it you can also read
a blog post and listen to an episode
titled how to build a world-class
network in record time but that is
additional credit this time we're going
to talk about the canvas strategy there
is some Latin pronunciation just a few
words in this episode and I'm sure
people will get their knickers in a
twist about how to say things properly
but it could be unpayable it could be
something else and ryan has done his
homework and I say Ryan because this is
from the brand new book by Ryan holiday
ego is the enemy and you might recall
that Ryan wrote the obstacle is the way
a collection of stoic wisdom and
principles and stories that was embraced
by people at the highest levels of
athletics the Seahawks the Patriots
managers players it just turned into a
phenomenon that was covered by Sports
Illustrated
I think ego is the enemy is just as good
if not better I saw early early editions
of the manuscript and provided feedback
it is therefore the newest book in my
book club there are only eight or nine
books over the last few years that I've
selected for this and you can see all of
them at audible.com forward slash Tim's
books
that's audible.com forward slash Tim's
books but this episode is very much
self-sufficient and I think it's a
lesson that more and more people need to
learn or at least embrace revisit in
their lives and that is the canvas
strategy so please enjoy the
description and this meandering
exploration with Ryan Holliday from ego
is the enemy follow the canvas strategy
great men have almost always shown
themselves as ready to obey as they
afterwards proved able to command Lord
male
in the Roman system of art and science
there existed a concept for which we
have only a partial analog successful
businessmen politicians or / rich
Playboy's would subsidize a number of
writers thinkers artists and performers
more than just being paid to produce
works of art these artists performed a
number of tasks in exchange for
protection food and gifts one of the
rules was that of an anthem Bulow
literally meaning one who clears the
path an anthem Bulow proceeded in front
of his patron anywhere they traveled in
Rome making way communicating messages
and generally making the patrons life
easier
the famous epigram is more shil
fulfilled this role for many years
serving for a time under the patron mila
a wealthy businessman and brother of the
stoat philosopher and political advisor
Seneca born without a rich family
Marshall also served under another
businessman named Petya Lea's as a young
writer he spent most of his day
travelling from the home of one rich
patron to another providing services
paying his respects and receiving small
token payments and favors in return
here's the problem like most of us with
our internships and entry-level
positions were later on publishers or
bosses or clients Marshall absolutely
hated every minute of it
he seemed to believe that this system
somehow made him a slave aspiring to
live like some Country Squire at the
patrons he serviced Marshall wanted
money and the state that was all his own
there he dreamed he could finally
produce his works in peace and
independence as a result his writing
often drags with a hatred and bitterness
about Rome's upper crust from which he
believed he was cruelly shunted aside
for all his impotent rage what Marshall
couldn't see was that it was his unique
position as an outsider to society that
gave him such a fascinating insight into
Roman culture that it survives to this
day instead of being pained by such a
system what have you been able to come
to terms with it
what if gasp he could have appreciated
the opportunities it offered nope it
seemed to eat him up inside instead
it's a common attitude that transcends
generations and societies the angry
underappreciated genius is forced to do
stuff she doesn't like for people she
doesn't respect as she makes her way in
the world how dare they forced me to
grovel like this the injustice the waste
we see it in recent lawsuits in which
interns sue their employers for pay we
see it in kids more willing to live at
home with their parents than submit to
something they're overqualified for we
see it in an inability to meet anyone
else on their terms an unwillingness to
take a step back in order to potentially
take several steps forward I will not
let them get one over on me I'd rather
we both have nothing instead it's worth
taking a look at the supposed
indignities of serving someone else
because in reality not only is the
apprentice model responsible for some of
the greatest art in the history of the
world everyone from Michelangelo to
Leonardo da Vinci to Benjamin Franklin
has been forced to navigate such a
system but if you're going to be the big
deal your thinker going to be isn't this
a rather trivial imposition when someone
first gets a job or joins a new
organization he's often given this
advice make other people look good and
you will do well keep your head down
they say and serve your boss naturally
this is not what the kid who was chosen
over all the other kids for the position
wants to hear it's not what a Harvard
grad expects after all they got that
degree precisely to avoid this supposed
indignity let's flip it around so it
doesn't seem so demeaning
it's not about kissing ass it's not
about making someone look good it's
about providing the support so that
others can be good the better wording
for this advice is then find canvases
for other people to paint on be an
anthem Bulow clear the path for people
above you and you will eventually create
a path for yourself
when you're just starting out we can be
sure of a few fundamental realities one
you're not nearly as good or as
important as you think you are - you
have an attitude that needs to be
readjusted three most of what you think
you know or most of what you learn in
books or in school is out of date or
wrong there's one fabulous way to work
all of that out of your system attach
yourself to people and organizations who
are already successful and subsume your
identity into theirs and move both
forward simultaneously it's certainly
more glamorous to pursue your own glory
though hardly as effective obeisance is
the way forward that's the other side of
this attitude it reduces your ego at a
critical time in your career letting you
absorb everything you can without the
obstructions that block others vision
and progress no one is endorsing
sycophancy instead it's about seeing
what goes on from the inside and looking
for opportunities for someone other than
yourself
remember that anthem below means
clearing the path finding the direction
someone already intended ahead and
helping them pack freeing them up to
focus on their strengths in fact making
things better rather than simply looking
as if you are many people know of
Benjamin Franklin's famous letters
written under names like silence dogwood
what a clever young prodigy they think
and miss the most impressive part
entirely Franklin wrote those letters
submitted them by sliding them under the
print shop door and received absolutely
no credit for them to a much later in
his life in fact it was his brother the
owner who profited from their immense
popularity regularly running them on the
front page of his newspaper
Franklin was playing the long game
though learning how public opinion
worked generating awareness of what he
believed in crafting his style and tone
and wit it's a strategy he used time and
again over in his career one's even
publishing in his competitors paper in
order to undermine a third competitor
for Franklin saw the constant benefit in
making other people look good and
letting them take credit for your ideas
bill belichick the
I'm super bowl-winning head coach of the
New England Patriots made his way up the
ranks of the NFL by loving and mastering
the one part of the job that coaches
disliked at the time analyzing film his
first job in professional football for
the Baltimore Colts was when he
volunteered to take without pay and his
insights which provided ammunition and
critical strategies for the game were
attributed exclusively to the more
senior coaches he thrived on what was
considered grunt work asked for it and
strove to become the best at precisely
what others thought they were too good
for he was like a sponge taking it all
in listening to everything one coach
said you gave him an assignment and he
disappeared into a room and you didn't
see him again until it was done and then
he wanted to do more sin another as you
can guess
Bellatrix started getting paid very soon
before that as a young high school
player he was so knowledgeable at the
game that he functioned as sort of an
assistant coach even while playing the
game Bellatrix father himself an
assistant football coach for Navy taught
him a critical lesson in football
politics that if he wanted to give his
coach feedback a question and decision
he needed to do it in private and
self-effacing Lee so as not to offend
his superior he learned how to be a
rising star without threatening or
alienating anyone in other words he'd
mastered the canvas strategy
you can see how easily entitlement and a
sense of superiority the trappings of
ego would have made the accomplishments
of either of these men impossible
Franklin never would have been published
if you'd prioritize credit over creative
expression
indeed when his brother found out he
literally beat him out of jealousy and
anger Belichick would have pissed off
his coach and then probably been benched
if he'd one-upped him in public he
certainly wouldn't have taken his first
job for free and he wouldn't have sat
through thousands of hours of film if
you cared about status greatness comes
from humble beginnings
it comes from grunt work it means that
you're the least important person in the
room and to change that with results
there is an old saying say little do
much what we really ought to do is
update and apply a version of that to
our early approach be lesser do more
imagine it for every person you met you
thought of some way to help them
something you could do for them and you
looked at it in a way that entirely
benefited them and not you the
cumulative effect this would have over
time would be profound you would learn a
great deal by solving diverse problems
you develop a reputation for being
indispensable you'd have countless new
relationships you'd have an enormous
Bank of favors to call upon down the
road that's what the canvas strategy is
about helping yourself by helping others
making a concerted effort to trade your
short-term gratification for a
longer-term payoff whereas everyone else
wants to get credit and be respected you
could forget credit you can forget it so
hard that you're glad when others get it
instead of you that was your aim after
all let others take their credit on
credit while you defer and earn interest
on the principle the strategy part of it
is the hardest it's easy to be bitter
like Marshall to hate even the thought
of subservience to despise those who
have more means more experience or
status than you to tell yourself that
every second not spent doing your work
or working on yourself is a waste of
your gift to insist I will not be
demeaned like this
once we fight this emotional and
egotistical impulse the canvas strategy
is easy the iterations are endless maybe
it's coming up with ideas to hand over
to your boss
find people thinkers up-and-comers to
introduce them to each other cross wires
to create new sparks find what nobody
else wants to do and do it find
inefficiency and waste and redundancies
identify leaks and patches to free up
resources for new areas produce more
than everyone else and give your ideas
away
in other words discover opportunities to
promote their creativity find outlets
and people for collaboration and
eliminate distractions that hinder their
progress and focus it's a rewarding and
infinitely scalable power strategy
consider each one an investment in
relationships and in your own
development the canvas strategy is there
for you at any time there's no
expiration date on it either it's one of
the few that age does not limit on
either side young or old you can start
at any time before you have a job before
you're hired and while you're doing
something else or if you're starting
something new or find yourself inside an
organization without strong allies or
support you may even find that there's
no reason to ever stop doing it even
once you've graduated to heading your
own projects let it become natural and
permanent let others apply it to you or
you're too busy applying it to those
above you because if you pick up this
mantle once you'll see what most
people's egos prevent them from
appreciating the person who clears the
path ultimately controls its direction
just as the canvas shapes the painting
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday the event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of
esoteric as I do it could include
favorite articles that I've read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a one-stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else I use 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times best seller they also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99designs designers around
the world to compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back
it's very simple you can check out a few
of my own designs and those of yours
meaning Tim Ferriss show listeners at 99
designs calm
/if Tim and right now my listeners you
guys will get a free $99 upgrade on your
first design that's 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim check it out this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash Tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you four
exactly the portfolio they put you in
and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it here's why the value of
wealth front is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally aren't great investing is a
marathon not a sprint
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than 10 asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show is because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have them on the podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealth front that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get fifteen
thousand dollars managed for free if you
decide to open an account but just start
with seeing the portfolio that they
would suggest for you take two minutes
fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of
you